and attractive. So you need to protect
her from having premarital sex for the
guy that she ends up with. No, Islam
doesn't say that. So just to be clear,
um Islam doesn't say that. Islam
protects Islam protects her so her value
doesn't drop. No, that can be maybe
something down there. Maybe a a a wisdom
somewhere down there. But the main
thing wisdom number one, that's wrong.
No, that's wrong. That's that's wrong
according to you. We're seeing that is
something they become less valuable when
they have sex. They do sorry they they
do sorry. Okay. Hey, look look such
a discussion.
I am a rever and I was taught how to
pray salah. That means every single time
I pray the person who told me gets the
reward five times a day from fud to Isa.
If you want to support someone like me
in learning salah then sponsor 10 people
for just $100 this Ramadan. Remember the
prophet peace be upon him said charity
does not decrease wealth. Click the
button and donate now.
My argument is like I mean part of my
argument is that a lot of the stuff in
here I don't feel like makes any sense
right like if this is objective truth
right
like it feels weird that if you get into
heaven you get a herm of virgins right
like that's one and again there are
things like this in it doesn't say in
there it doesn't is that a hadith yeah
it's a hadith yeah so that you get 72 2
virgins. What does it make sense? Why
doesn't it make sense? What's there not
to make sense about it? I mean, I I feel
like that's So, number one, it has this
I mean, it has this uh uh
No, hold it. We're both It has this
judgment statement on, you know,
virginity is the first thing, right?
like it it it it has this this man it
has this judgment on I mean particularly
women that have had sex before as if
that's less valuable than if like is it
not? No, I don't think that makes a
woman less valuable if she's had sex
before. You know when I think what's
worse is it when a man cheats or a woman
cheats in Islam they're both the same
sin but which one's worse? I don't think
either of them are worse. A woman can
ascribe a child to you that doesn't
belong to you. You can't do that. Yeah,
I don't. So, so what I'm saying is so
you see from certain paradigms the
reason why virginity matters because to
men it matters. Now you are saying that
because you have these preconceived
notions and your society has put
pressure under you over you like as a
man we believe if you was born um
without being affected by society you
will not have an issue with saying I
want a virgin. Every man would say I
don't want another man having having my
wife. Yes. Or or or my girlfriend
whatever for that matter. Yeah. Nobody
no man will come and say yeah I have no
problem you know if my wife had 50 uh uh
boyfriends or whatever even one as men
we are created to have protective
jealousy over our woman folk. So the
idea as the way we're created carries so
many so your argument is basically my
opinion most preferences as as men our
first preferences would you like if if
you get married would you say I would
like a wife that slept around or hasn't
slept with anybody so the default
position so my argument my
counterargument to you is that my
disagreement with you that virginity
doesn't actually really matter is that
it's informed by like western secular
ideals about you know like I mean the
counterargument to that which I think is
very easy to make is that yours is more
informed by like the culture. Like
there's been thousands of years of
favoritism towards of of sexism of just
social sexism towards women about
especially centered on women's sexual
activities and that continues today. So
Islam came to abolish that. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean again I so I'm talking about male
preference. I'm not talking about Islam.
In Islam it doesn't matter if a woman
she's a virgin or not. So what so what
I'm saying is if in Islam if if it's a
hadith obviously it's not to the same
level of Quran. So I'm not saying that
it's the word of God but if it's but if
it's in hadith that this preference
is codified.
Does that does that not say something
about the value judgment of like
Muhammad or the people who recorded what
Muhammad were saying? Like most it
carries a value judgment that I think
has been informed. Most of prophet's
wives were not virgins. Yeah. So, so
what I'm saying is as as a male
preference, I'm saying from the get-go,
we as men, we would not we would not
want to like which I think is I mean,
pardon my French, but I think that
that's I think men prefer
virgins. I think is informed by
thousands of years of of sexism, right?
Like No, no, no. Let's go back to what
I'm saying is in Islam, let me make this
clear. Firstly, I'm just talking about
from a a
male as as as in Islam, a woman who has
slept around, who was a prostitute. You
know, I shouldn't say. No, no, no, no,
no. That's right. No. They slept around
and all that kind of stuff. If she
repents, her repentance is accepted.
She's she is she is sinless. Islam Islam
accepts her. No problem. I'm talking
about male preferences here. Yeah. And
also at the same time, there is a hadith
that says it is better. It is preferred
that you do marry a virgin. It it is a
preference. It is the prophetam does
encourage that. But in heaven, what you
get these are these are not human. These
are not females that were judged on this
earth. These are specific beings that
have been created for men. And the
reason why the 72 version, even though
there's a whole discussion about it,
who's it for? Is it authentic? But let's
suppose we go with it. The the argument
is that it's a male male's preference
that when you buy a like I don't want to
obviously equate um cars to to females.
Yeah, exactly. I don't want to. But what
I would say is that for example that if
if whatever you like, for example, if
you married somebody, you would not want
her to know that another man was
intimate with her. That's natural. I'm
saying except the natural side. Why is
there no corresponding hadith for women
who make it into heaven that they get
like 72 virgin or just men? Not even
virgin but just men. Because because No,
no, no. They get they will they will
have their husband because the way God
almighty has created them is that a
woman does not have the propensity to
want more than one man. Women are
monogous by nature. Yeah. So are so are
men. No, they're not. Yes, they are. No,
they're not. Okay, let me tell you.
There there are animals there are
animals that are monogamous by nature.
There are animals that kill other
animals. Yeah. And my point is it's not
So you're talking biologically. Your
your argument is that biologically men
are are more attracted. Like you're
making you're making a biological
argument. And my and my biological
argument to you is that there is
evidence biologically that men and
additional animals. So it's not just
humans. Let's stick with humans. Well,
no. I'm saying cuz it's important to
include other animals in this cuz we are
we're not we're not animals. We don't
believe animals. I mean, yeah. Are you
are you trying to make a biological
argument or are you not? Because
biologically we are animals. No, no.
What's the definition of animal? What
are you talking about? What's your
what's your definition? There's a scient
there's an empirical scientific
definition of organism. I mean, I don't
have it off the top of my head, but that
doesn't mean that I'm wrong in
your argument is that if you're making
if you're trying to say, okay, the the
virgin the haram of virgins is not a a
religious thing. It's just a simple
biological preference for the re the
rationale behind that. You can't you
can't pick and choose which biological
reasoning you're willing to include and
which ones you want to exclude. My
biological argument is that we are
animals and there is evidence in humans
and in other animals that there is a
biological preference for monogamy in
some animals. I'm not saying all of
course I'm talking about humans. So So
yeah and that's cuz we're disagreeing
about animal human. I'm saying let's
just talk about humans cuz we're
disagreeing about you deemed us to be
animals. I don't believe animals. Okay.
Well, so my point is either biologically
the reasoning behind hadith the hadith
is that biologically men have a
preference for virgins in which case we
can use biological rationale to come to
the conclusion that it's false or we
cannot use biological principles to
understand what the hadith like why the
hadith ascribes that and in that case I
think that that indicates a moral flaw
on that hadith and that's a larger
theological question I think so you're
choosing like the problem with the
conversation that we're having right now
is you're picking and choosing when you
want to use biological rale based on how
it suits what you're trying to say.
You're using you're using the biological
rale to understand. To watch the full
discussion guys just click the link here
or in the description box in this will
take you to my new daer channel Ali Dawa
Raw where from now on all my da
discussions will be aired. Go now and
subscribe now and enjoy this video
inshallah on that channel. Asalam
alaikum.